[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
this makes me feel like someone's gonna
burst through sadly no one's gonna burst
through boy it's closed hey everyone
welcome to another day of games was
playful all event we are giving you all
of the big game coverage you'd expect
god it's weird that this would be III
week very strange yeah we would be at
you three right now but also we are
doing daily charity livestreams for co
feed relief going money going to Direct
Relief as well as black lives matter the
donate links are on the screen right now
so today for today's chattering Tamar
and I are joined by Troy Baker man it
makes so much more sense know why I feel
like trying to drink it you know 11
o'clock in the morning yeah that makes
way more saying I did a tweet the other
day which was like I'm glad I don't
drink because if I did it was right now
I would definitely be drinking non-stop
and I would not be able to but like in
in like I'm freely admit like there's an
element of FOMO of not having a this is
gonna sound weird but like something
that allows you to escape that easily or
like take the edge off that easily like
I don't have a thing for that right now
more may I remind you you live in
California I mean like I have I have
that but they're readily available to
you this is this is you know how like
dev sound like a dev beer this is yours
is a stress beer this is a quarantine
beer music like and you can like and
like play dough emerge from your chin no
the the beauty of you is is that all of
the like we're just talking about dice
and we're talking with this being III
week you have like a black mail folder
full just like of everybody you're like
if anytime you ever just wanted to go
hey I could push that button and III
party 2019 is primarily why I'm like so
everyone's like you gotta be careful of
that guy he's walking straight he hasn't
had a single drink
charming and effusively nice and and
everybody just loves to hang out with
you and they're like wait a minute what
kind of remember last night why am I on
a stream with Troy Baker and somehow
being complimented let's focus on joy
here oh I love complimenting you what's
up what's going on in your world guys
not a lot so I mean plenty talked about
this and yeah talked about his stream
I'm gonna be keeping an eye on both the
donations that we have and the chat for
any sort of questions but as far as I
know we don't really have a set agenda
we're just gonna hang out and chat and
talk about things and keep it chill over
the host part yeah inevitably we'll end
up talking about the life of times of
Trey Baker and the illustrious career of
Troy Baker probably but we can talk
about the life that the times are
strictly off the table okay iris iris
yes I my life is this right now dude I
spend more time in this this room within
these four walls and I think there's
four walls maybe there's more than four
walls because there's a part of it
but yeah this has become like home
home-based for me and I I have like
right right when quarantine started it
was like whoa dude what are we gonna do
because how do I have like most people
trying to figure I was like well how do
we work and fortunately I'm in an
industry number one where it's full of
professional problems so like that's
that's what devs do right they they they
go alright let's let's create a problem
and then on the back end of it let's
solve it and so games fortunately for by
and large there's a few that
obviously pushed and pause for a little
bit but then others were like at the
perfect point in their dev cycle where
they could just kind of keep cranking
mm-hmm
I had on one title that we can't talk
about one morning at a courier show up
to my front door and there were four
Pelican cases and it was like here you
go
and ends inside of this where like all
of the gear for helmet cams and they're
like let's see if we can do a flow
fishing huh
well facial capture at least yeah but
there's there's talk of trying to do
mocap they're like how big is your
studio I'm like mm-hmm
so mate I mean if you could essentially
if you could set up a like a oculus or
or a vibe you know set up then you could
do that here cuz it's the same tracking
thing right especially now that oculus
you can track track your hands is so
freakin cool I'm looking at Michaelmas
right now yeah I was gonna Greg's got a
vibe he got it for I know he has the
indexing he's got index for when
half-life came out but my my issue with
VR is that I get motion sick incredibly
easily nice yeah um although vibe was
the one that gave me the least amount of
trouble I'm still I'm I used to live
with a friend of mine he was a developer
and he had an oculus development kit -
okay and he decided to hook that up to
half-life 2 that was single-handedly the
worst experience I think I've ever yeah
well no it was the tracking was off
completely and it was and the latency
was so bad because it just wasn't wired
up properly and I don't know why if
that's giving me a weird Pavlovian
response to any kind of VR do you know
what the cure for the motion sickness
friend Vieira's Jinja
what does she have to do with this your
job is better than mine no no no I was
just they don't do it but you're joking
well you're a joke it was like an
apothecary come here put this under your
tongue I went to I remember going to one
of the first ever it was a first press
showing of this VR game a coin remote it
was called but the guy who ran the
studio it was a first-person adventure
title so a lot of ducking and
interacting with objects and reading
things the guy who ran the studio was so
motion sick in VR I had to stop after
ten minutes cuz I got too sick he had to
take over and he was basically retching
his way through the demo then but then
the PR had like this massive selection
of ginger biscuits and ginger home
remedies cuz apparently that offsets the
nausea right it does my my first
experience was I think I've told this
story before my first experience was
that I think it's called VR zoom but it
was like VR strapped to a bicycle and
you are very bicycle but within the game
you were riding on a horse so I did that
and I was like okay horse riding I can
kind of try and make this work and it
was making me feel sick what the
developer didn't say is there's actually
a twist to it where once you reach a
certain speed of pedaling your horse
becomes a Pegasus and begins flying and
like did not tell me that
so like I'm pedaling immediately this
virtual horse that looks like it's you
know rendered in on a Playstation one
suddenly takes off and immediately my
fight-or-flight just instinct like
kicked in and I just I just like like I
was like I need to get off this I wasn't
sure if you like we started fighting the
horse which way did you go this time
took like did you take fight I that
would be a that sounds like something
that jokes Topher would know about
because he had like been a huge
proponent especially for any kind of VR
that it would that fully engages you in
as is immersive in the sense of like
involving your body
he lost I don't know how much weight
like yeah a lot these are this he's huge
like proponent ouvea because we were um
that Jeanne dikes that we were around
this year he was there and he was like
pitching me on VR I was like man I trust
me I want to be behind this but like if
you follow him on Twitter you can see
and or or anywhere else you can see he
posts like regular updates and he's got
like a room set up going where dude he
looks like the only guy in the club vo
club and it's like just where you gonna
dance and I'm like you see that guy
doing beat Sabre and it is just like
he's like Force Unleashed man it's crazy
no pun intended for Force Unleashed and
saver being says I was actually gonna
ask you there when we started talking
about your work already but like you you
getting into doing motion capture I was
gonna ask like are you in a situation
where you are kind of able to do the
voice work stuff but then it kind of
when you said to fit you know faceful
facial capture it reminded of that quote
that you said like a little while back
or it was like the quarry is a lot of
your people asking you how to become a
voice actor enjoy drop the voice and
just be an actor so oh yeah I thought
you were setting up for the dice joke
that I so whereas like bike it might get
away from Nolan North and I to die but
yeah like how's that how's that been for
you like are you like what you're doing
or people like really like we need to
get full mode Kevin sending the suit
send him everything the full like P
Capra is is maybe coming we're gonna I
think people are being there's one shoot
that I was supposed to do or as actually
I was gonna to do it out of country
doesn't matter where but and obviously I
couldn't do that
so we started taking a look at well then
what can I do and so ultimately it just
had to be like we're going to do the P
cap here and you're going to have to do
the The Voice and hopefully face here in
my room but the the beauty of it is that
like everybody still wants to watch like
cartoons of video games so all the
animated series that I'm on
I obviously get still do like promo work
and everything but the the ability to
still be able to do some games has been
really cool and I just I've got my booth
in there my my setup is pretty dope
the day after we're like what the
quarantine was the day that like Sony
Disney Warner Brothers although all
these people were like should we test
your rig and see what it would it if
it's capable of handling what we want to
do and it's always fun to get on with
because there's some people that are
like I don't know how to turn this thing
on and then you've got me where this is
my golf like I if there was any other
thing that I needed to do in the
quarantine I would be IV I be screwed
but because it has to deal with like can
you do audio game like that's I've been
waiting for this so like I have all my
gear I beat up my my home rig they
computer and everything but I have like
six screens here I have one in the or I
have one two three four screens here one
in the booth and I've got like a music
station over here so like I am I gonna
set I was like your quarantine this is
your bunker yeah I I built my own I'm a
huge Mortal Kombat fan and I've had like
the the Raspberry Pi I was able to do
like all of the emulators that you can
do all the different games or whatever
and so I have a ps3 fight stick like a
Mortal Kombat like official fight stick
and so I like I like I'm looking over at
it right now because it's so bored this
but I put it up and I like put a little
monitor psych f7 up there so I can
actually claim like Mortal Kombat and I
just all I care abouts one through three
I mean I mean up 10 and 11 was just like
awesome and it's still somehow is
fatalities always are fun mmm but
there's just an even Ed Boon I think he
said that Mortal Kombat 3 is it's like
favorite at least at that time favorite
version of it once they introduced the
Run button it was Karen and I were in
there
there was no Raiden you get to get it
was that's that's that's the best and I
as much as I love consoles there's still
so much of me especially right now when
it's when I want comfort or whatever I
picture myself there's some people that
picture themselves you know with
controller in hand I'm at a stand up
arcade some reason there's just I miss
being in that environment
I miss the dim lights and the the smells
and the sounds of an arcade and maybe
that's one reasons why I still like
Vegas reminds me of being in heaven has
you ever voiced or been involved in like
a game that's in arcades
have to be I mean I imagine like your
voice has been used in like some sort of
promotional thing with in my case there
was some like there was some Marvel I
think it's like Marvel vs. Capcom like
yeah yeah well because you keep you
didn't OVA in yeah ultimate so maybe but
I know for sure we did like Moon Knight
beard for the pinball oh oh there's some
Joker stuff that we did for pinball
there's a lot of like the big 4d rides
that I've done stuff for either like
Marvel or DC it does a big arena thing
sort of so there's definitely that but
like I maybe yeah maybe wait to city in
it arcade yeah yeah oh yeah huge so you
think you've been doing diet bar right
you know talking about in Japan okay Oh
judge joy palace or whatever it is yeah
there is I don't know if it's still
there and I hope that it is there's this
bride guess you would call it called
room of the living dolls
oh well it's there's no like
it's all in Japanese so you come in and
it's just a small like dining table
where I think like four people on this
side four people on this side and he
likes it like on a wouldn't you you sit
down on a chair and then they give you
headphones you put headphones off
and all around the room up on this
railing our little freebie dolls they're
just like staring down at you and then
at the end is an empty chair
and he's telling us the story we don't
understand any of it and then he closes
the door and it's pitch black
you can't see your hand in front of your
face much less the person across from
you the door opens
and you see somebody move in that it's
slammed shut
and the lights go out and all of a
sudden you hear this voice from where
the chair is
this creepy old woman and sort of like
okay so those could be lists of creepy
thing where they kind of come burn out
at her and all sudden like and she's
walking right up to me I'm like of
course she picked the dude that hi don't
I freak out and stuff like this like I'm
not good scary movies it's not my thing
and she just decides to get right down
in my ear and is whispering in my ear
and all of a sudden I hear her like
pulled out some scissors and she puts
the scissors next to my ear and she's
talking about how much she loves to cut
the hair of her dolls and I feel she
goes snip and she cuts I feel my hair go
free and often cuz a lock of my hair I'm
like wait a minute and then all of a
sudden she's screaming and we hear these
dolls all descend like this little
creepy little doll voices starts coming
and they're running around and then hear
a shotgun [ __ ] I'm like what is
happening right now and a boo and I feel
this impact on my chest and my chair
falls through the floor like whoa has to
be like three four five feet and I'm on
my back and I'm like holy crap and I
hear the voice way high up above us that
I've fallen through the floor so she's
still up there and she's basically
telling me you could be buried here
forever ha I laugh and then all of a
sudden my chair comes up lights come on
and we haven't moved at all and it was
all in the headphones no okay no I had a
table and a tiny air cannons that were
right here so when you hear that snip
you feel your mind makes the connection
our our seats tilted back like maybe
four inches and then dropped four inches
and it came back up and it but it made
you feel like you fell like to your
death teenaged is the scariest coolest
experience and and everybody else had
the same experience because they all
felt them the woman all will be coming
to their ears well we all like looked at
each other and were like oh holy [ __ ]
that was the coolest thing ever so if
you're ever in Japan I don't lie about I
think the third floor of joy plus by the
day best cure for a hangover because I
went there super hungover Oh balls would
you kill him I went in God's vanilla ice
cream at the other little commissary
they serve Anila ice cream french fries
and ginger oh my god
that stuff we went out why in in like
from the vending machines and from just
the convenience those buy it's designed
specifically to lessen the impact of
hangovers if not eliminate it I I miss
Japan man I
I lived there for two months I have been
there twice yeah I live there once for
like I think we were there for three
weeks shooting a game that never came
out
and then we lived there for two months
doing a game that unfortunately came out
called Binary Domain hey hey hey hey hey
you're not if you tell me you hey hey
hey hey
winery domain is a underrated fantastic
game and you should be proud of your
work involved in it what Binary Domain
is it didn't sell well maybe that's the
man did not it did not well honestly
like there is a binary domain fanbase
how there is you it's got a robot that
wears an X cough come on by John John
Demeter it should have been a next-gen
console game yeah because the branching
narrative aspect of it was supercool but
so we had to shoot multiple versions of
that scene depending upon who you chose
to take with you and your relationship
with them so that's why we were there
for two months it's because the
narrative of it was massive my accent
was Terry what accent is it that was
2012 right sure yeah and so that is the
game was one of the few games created by
Ryu go-go boots to do which is the yes
this is the yuck as a team and it was
yeah it's designed by Teixeira nagashi
and genuinely like people really really
loved it and it's like thought of as a
game that because it wasn't like really
scrutinize and analyze a lot of what it
did wasn't explored properly and so like
the critical reception wasn't super
positive but is one of those games where
it's like if you dig into it it's got a
lot of and it's fun the shooting felt
great and it was like really had a lot
of heart to it so hey enemy had a decent
story yeah not a great story but a
decent story and they
Oh art alone the cover art alone is
enough you know groan the cover is not
great and the the perspective on the
character motto is not great but you
played a character called Charles
Gregory it was a spawning born in the
United Kingdom so you mentioned earlier
that your accent was all over it was all
over the place and there was a lot of
like jr. scheana was at the time was
who's the producer on that you know June
where did he go
he went on he was on yeah yeah yeah he
was a web born um yeah sure it was so
great because he was just he's he's like
he's like a Japanese polish or he's just
super chill and just laid-back crazy
hair and he had piercings and everything
but you could always tell like when he
needed to be a little bit more corporate
to it this like dress up a little bit
more but we were stronger the team was
Japanese so we were trying to be very
mindful of how he communicated and
everything so the first time that I met
June I was like it's an honor to meet
you thank you so much for having us like
yeah my school goofy I'm like oh okay
how much you understood about what I
said
but we had such a great time and Ezra
those were good times travis willingham
played the lead holler if you're dead
that was the cat Alice's catchphrase Oh
Palmer if you're dead
but Travis we all were like hey all of
us get paid the same amount no matter
what and they were like okay I were like
good deal we did a good thing for
everybody except for the fact that there
are some people that were like oh by the
way you're gonna be off for the next
week so if I do whatever you want Travis
worked every day was in every scene he
was first in and last mouth worked like
a dog on that thing man I mean just like
and it was the the stage was right on
the wharf and we did it in July and
August we were there
so it was just the hottest months and
then I I literally left there I got no
time to do anything but stay inside of
Tokyo but I like they some people went
off to Kyoto III stayed there and then I
came back and literally landed in LA got
picked up and went straight to a studio
and worked on Saints Row 4 for the next
looming I wasn't I so I didn't live in
my apartment I wasn't home for like a
solid three months I actually the first
time I drove back to my apartment
because I lived at the studio that we
were doing saints row at and I drove
past my apartment I was like oh [ __ ]
that I had to turn back rounds like I
really drove past my building
dang we're gonna we're gonna oh I was I
was gonna say before we we're gonna come
back to your British accent but before
we do that I just want to remind
everyone please remember to donate using
the links below you can see it where
country we're raising money for black
lives matter and kovat relief we had
some donations yesterday which we didn't
get a chance to read so I'm just gonna
quickly route through them please bye
Harvey $25 chip vinyl whose $100 Brian
Ross $25 Wendy Gregory $25 those were
all to black lives matter and then we
had Jared miles twenty dollars anonymous
donated $5 bryce 35 laughing heart $1
neo Falcon GX five dollars and then only
melts five dollars towards kovat relief
I'm on the website TV Tropes thought org
and under under Troy Baker one of the
achievements that you've got is fake
Brit and it says he's really good in
really is in italics to her pulling off
British accents and it asked invites the
rear to compare November 11 excalibur
hazel Charles Gregory all on Vanka
Sinestro Loki and jet fire so do you
reckon your your British accent has come
along a long way now
much but here is the best yeah cuz a lot
of those are passable and some are
laughable
but you're in a room with two Brits so
we can rate your breakfast right now the
beauty of it is that Mike Bissell
whenever I try to cuz I've worked with
Mike on a couple of things and Mike's
great I've always like hey dude can I do
it Britney's no can't do one it was like
in your defense he was like it's it's
it's perfectly good I was like great so
he's and he's a man of discriminating
taste I feel like my best British accent
that I've done was foreshadowed Italian
in shadow record work because I put him
in a very they said you know obviously
they kind of the print for this would be
like a Sean Bean I'm like oh cool so
like Kent Sheffield kind of like
Midlands north and kind of thing and
they're like yeah and so dialing into
that so that's if I ever do a British
accent everyone's like oh you do a
British accent Lee well what does that
mean like where are you from
are you from like Liverpool he from
Manchester you from London are you from
Bristol even has like a different accent
so I basically just want to live there
that's kind of that's what I want to do
and it's funny because a lot of I spend
a lot of time in the UK and if I'm there
for any amount of period of time I
slowly start just kind of gravitating
towards that and the Simmons likes to
where you from it was like living it
later like what is I'm one of you now
but like I have my my especially in
London I've got my little like quadrants
blocked off and it's that's a great
feeling got me and I miss London
Sailor Venus stuck is a weird word it's
more like now that the option to go back
has been closed off oh yeah
cuz I'm a man I'm not even from London
but I called it home for six years I'm
I'm from Newcastle I was gonna say
you're from the north there's a fake
accent yeah ten where you from I'm from
well I was born in Pakistan
I've raised in East London
oh [ __ ] Far East London year big up
Leytonstone it's on the far right-hand
side of the central line all the way in
the east like Diane's East like almost
like keep yes a little further well oh
yeah yeah it's proper proper East East
London so I was always feel like
Docklands was like the drop-off point
there's like and now no there's no
civilization beyond this I used to live
in the Docklands I used to live in
Canary Wharf and the only civilization
there are the bankers there there's
nothing well I remember like when MCM
first started out there and it was you
took the you you took with the tower
gateway and then you took the DLR was
the only way that you could get into the
Docklands and there was [ __ ] all there
like it was there was the o2 well done
oh now it's all like rich people live
there playing yeah because wanting to be
a big shopping center - so they're gonna
change that big the circle bit and then
you know inside is still gonna be arena
but they're gonna make a huge shopping
centre and they tried to make Greenwich
North Greenwich like a residential area
yeah but it's like hard for anyone but
the most upper-class to live there so
it's classic gentrification yeah it's
the same thing with London man like you
know kids live in London are you kidding
me
yeah even well where I'm from East
London like I I was raised there and I
grew up in like blocks of flats council
estates like really like rough
upbringing but now when the Olympics
happened like the prep the housing price
everywhere around us was developed to
the point where it became difficult for
the people who were there to even live
there and so like it was being like the
the gentrification that happened in that
area was extreme around the Olympics
they like yeah created my brand new
Westfield Center and that meant that
like too small and me there was just so
there's a Westfield Center in Stratford
and the opposite is this really small it
was there it always was there it's a
shopping center that had the same shots
but it was like not aware
Center but you go there now and it the
amazing thing about it was it was such
it was such a charming place it's such
full of heart so they had like around
the outskirts of it was it's just like a
five minute walk from one side to the
other so around the outskirts of it were
all these shops and in the middle there
just be this group of kids that were
always just doing skateboard tricks and
playing golf and it was like the most
East London thing that you would see and
they were like super nice chilled out
dudes well-behaved just doing tricks for
themselves they'd like occasionally
skate around if a kid was interested
they're trying to show them how to skate
and that kind of stuff that place is
just abandoned now there's no one there
because the Westfield Center showed up
you changed it so we went a friend of
ours had his birthday there a few years
ago and the rooftop of that Center is
now this huge outdoor area with loads of
bars and good food and like cornhole and
batting cages and stuff so they've kind
of tried to make it more community sort
of vibe but that shopping center
underneath is yeah just literally in the
last two minutes your New Castle just
came out I was great I reminded you of
home and all sudden they start the more
lyrical there's like a little to it I I
planned without or like customer service
phone calls yeah cuz I do that because
Jordy got voted the like nicest accent
in the UK see there it is
and it's meant to be very calming and
usually if I'm calling customer service
about something I need something and so
I'm you know just quite man I appreciate
your your honesty in that I with the
kind accent what you call it Jordi Jordi
yeah so uh you had Jersey Shore over
here yeah cuz the Jersey Shore was you
know a lot of booze people not wearing a
lot of clothes a lot of fighting our
version Geordie Shore similar except
many many degrees colder which makes the
people not wearing as many colors very
strange
yeah but equally is compelling
I do remember did you ever go to the 12
bar club in in London it was like like
the stones played there and then they
moved to Camden and then I just like
shut down it was like that hole where
like the the underground music scene in
London used to be and then all of a
sudden it was like that we can't afford
to be here because they were there like
the sixties and seventies and then it
was like that whole air like you said
it's like that's where the shots are
coming in and you can't you can't afford
to live there it's that there's a
and the interests of making things safer
I feel like safe it could be being
expensive doesn't equal safe
because it I don't know we get an owl
conversation I don't like the fact of
this notion that in order to protect
yourself you must make it incredibly
expensive and difficult to get to
I feel like instead it just needs to be
more about education and perceived value
it's like don't you know you need to
know what that building is and you
understand why it's there and what has
happened there and if we walked around
where everything felt more like that's
the problem with in the States is by and
large there's just no history there's no
attachment to a lineage and and a
connection to our past which is one of
the beautiful thing that's happening
right now is people are standing up and
going in front of my sent me a book he
was like I've never read this book but I
feel like it's most important thing for
me to read it's Malcolm X he's like I
need to understand like this is and I
think John Oliver shared something on
his show talking about how a statement
that was read in in the 60s he said the
same situation so problem and solution
was presented in the riots of 1919 of
1965 and today he was like this is there
is no progress there was no change and I
sincerely hope that
[Music]
this is an opportunity because the world
is standing up and taking notice that
it's it's a I really do feel like we're
gonna look back and go I remember where
I was this week I'm gonna do it is the
perfect storm we've never been in the
situation before no one ever in our
history much less my life as someone
ever said you can't go outside like you
don't get to go wherever you want ever
we've we've always been able to afford a
certain amount of Liberty and I think
that at a conversation with an amazing
professor and anthropologist named Alice
Roberts and I said that
you know kovat has been like the great
equalizer she said no it's not because
it's still affecting people
disproportionately but I think that and
I agree with her but I also think that
there's been this
everybody gets a little taste right now
of what it feels like to not be able to
do what you want to get what you want
and I think that has seeded the fact
sadly that that's what it's taken for a
lot of people to stand up and go this is
wrong it's like yeah now that every day
of your life and of your father's life
of your grandfather's life and if
nothing changes that their sons and
daughters life and their son dog's life
so it's been a really beautiful time
it's I feel like we as humans are almost
in this phase of being Phoenix
to where yeah we're burning right now
but I my hope is that we're able to
emerge from this all
[Music]
better and beautiful creatures from the
ashes of this so yeah absolutely and you
can help people do that by donating into
a Segway yeah we have that Phoenix rises
from the ashes we hope you can help that
you know happen by contributing to
causes like Direct Relief that we are
raising money for which is supporting
health care workers who are fighting you
know on the front lines of covet efforts
and you can see our link down there bit
or alewife or - yes - covered and then
we're also raising money for black lives
matter and like Troy said like there are
certain communities that are
disproportionately affected by what's
happening and not just racial and
Justices and systemic so she's also in
Justices but also kovat like the the
black community is severely
disproportionately affected so you can
donate to both of those causes if you
can and it really helps I want to go
back to that thing that you said where
you know just because it looks you know
shiny it doesn't make it necessarily
better there's an interesting kind of
example of that where I lived in Lane
stones so I live in Lane stone and you
can walk to Stratford which is like
maybe a 20 to 40 minute walk but there's
nothing the area in between I actually
used to live in the area in between as
well I've lived in almost every part of
this and the area in between is treated
as like almost like you don't want to go
there's kind of like the projects is
kind of like you get all so people
generally have that image of that area
that they just try to avoid it so if
they want to go to Stratford instead of
walking from Leytonstone through that
area which is generally safe and
perfectly fine it's just the image of it
create that the years ago is different
they take the train but along that path
there's a pub and that pub was the first
pub that led serpent later in the UK so
it's down the road from us and most
people have no idea it's that pub
because they don't walk from you go near
that pub and it's proudly like displayed
on the walls I said well it says like
Led Zeppelin played here this is the
first place they played and but no one
knows it because they jump on a train
they bypass that entire section and they
they kind of
pop out on the other side to do their
shopping Westfield Center but I used to
live there so I would like I was forced
to look around and what you were saying
there like just because it's richer
doesn't mean it's better like the areas
in between sure there might be some
sketchy areas but there's always
something there that's interesting and
that's what makes a city or makes a
place memorable those kind of the things
that aren't on the the obvious path
they're off the air and it's sorry I'm
sorry it's kind of why every time I go
to a new city I love to do the open tour
bus especially one never been there
because like otherwise I'm just gonna
walk around I'm gonna miss everything
but then you have someone yelling in
your ear you know you should look at
this and this and the one in New York is
amazing so it's like hey and this is the
first ever elevator in the world was in
this tiny nondescript building well how
on earth would you know that unless you
know someone's there telling you hmm
I there's a person that I'm working with
and now as a producer for the channel
named Tom he started off as an intern
with with retro replay and then I
branched off and did my thing he was
like I want to come with you and my kick
ass is could do some stuff together um I
I want he's never been to you know he
moved from Connecticut to Boston and
then went to LA and
I was like what I mean you've been to
whatever he was like no he had never
been anywhere in LA I was like man
there's there's places that I I've lived
in LA for almost 15 years
and I've I've never been to the Getty
Center and it's literally like I mean
not even five miles from my house and
I've never been my wife has been
traveler my son has been like three
times but you just
there's always something like ah and
it's like the same thing with the with
the ocean like we we live 15 miles from
the ocean and especially right now with
like no traffic we could be there in 20
minutes
and you get to see a beautiful force of
nature that you never get to experience
and I was like man we really should
every time I go they're like we've
really should do this more often and we
don't it's the same thing it's like a
lot of times I feel like what you need
is you need someone going hey have you
ever seen Blanc and then having someone
come to you and take you there so now
it's not just like like you said the
open tour of us is great but you're kind
of dependent upon someone giving you but
you're seeing it through their lens or
you're seeing just a very factual
there's that building that has this
thing and that's it as opposed to let me
take you to my favorite place in LA and
it's this like pull in the wall taco
place and you're like here's my story
behind this and then being able to share
that I think helps you it helps me
understand like whenever someone takes
me to their place like I'm gonna take
you to my favorite restaurant where I
got to take you to the place where I
first fell in love with LA or whatever
it is I what it does is it imbues me
with understanding that note number one
it reinforces the notion that were
social creatures in that it's important
for us to remain connected to each other
and share each other's stories but also
that a place no one can tell me like the
place can't tell me that it's important
but someone can tell me why it's
important to them and if it's important
to them and they're a human and I'm a
human then therefore it can become
important to me or I need to go and find
my version of that old hole in the wall
taco place um that's why we named our
son traveller it's like you need to
understand that this is a big world but
it's a very very special world and you
do yourself an injustice if you don't go
out and experience different cultures
different people different places
different things if we live within our
own block
and we have our like you said Tim it's
like this is the view that we've always
had AddThis you're gonna miss the first
place that Led Zepplin ever played but
you have to know where to go you're
gonna miss the first elevator in the in
the in the world you have to go and
experience it and once you do that once
I do that the more places that I
experience the more I realize it's like
man we're really different but we're
really really the same where there's
there's so much about us that's so
similar and that brings a certain level
of humanity and therefore compassion so
the people that I deal with because
we're all the same
hmm I think one the interesting like
challenges of it is not challenges of it
but something that I'm trying to be more
mindful of is being aware of where you
are as well not just like having people
show you but like being cognizant and
having like a situational awareness like
it came to me when I was in university
and I was in university I went to the
University of Westminster in central
London it's like in Oxford Circus and no
I went I went there for four years and
on my final week as I was leaving I
looked at this kind of like you know you
have this like sugar glass kind of you
know you know you have glass and they
put like a little decal on it that but
it's like it's also kind of white and
you can't really tell what it is like I
stood back and looked at what what is
this like what does it say and it was
just like a big sign and a picture that
said Jimi Hendrix played here and it was
just a picture of Jimi Hendrix that's
like I have been in this University for
years I had no idea like Hendrix and
like I was into Hendrix pectin mainly
because of our galactic over story but
like I was into Hendrix back then and I
had no clue but like having that
situational awareness is also like super
important because even if it's not a
place that's special to someone that
shows you like you know if it's not you
know troy saying this is my favorite
restaurant or lucy saying this is my you
know favorite elevator the way you've
been lumbered with elevators you can
like find just by having that awareness
of you at the world around you you can
find something of value in there for
yourself and that could be something
that you pass on even if it's just like
a standard street
not like a you know an important
building or something like that but it
could be like you know I went to the
pier the other day and I just saw a man
fishing and I was like this is like now
an important place because I haven't to
this point in America I've not actually
seen a person fishing now I've seen a
person fishing and it's an important
place to my time here now and you can
share that with other people so like
that situational awareness is also super
important it's gonna say cuz you and I
moved here I moved here September 2018
you were August 29 2019 yeah you both
really fortunate that we knew people
here already because you know moving to
a new country so scary but having people
here already to kind of take you around
and show you these things mostly it was
the hey this is the regular games for
IGN watering holes you know then you go
out every so often it's like hey let's
go to the park for the weekend you know
we didn't know what this park was we
were talking to a friend and your gold
fob today cuz I can't believe you
abandoned us to go like this is where
I'm gonna be alright my job here is done
and he just leaves
[Music]
morning in Pokemon book reminding us of
that day and I think that was the first
time either of Tom and I had been to
Japan town here in San Francisco and he
was showing us around and we it's weird
that I don't know maybe this is the way
that my mind works I don't piece
together that is one day I piece it
together kind of like Google Maps ish
you know you know when you go on your
phone and it shows you where photos were
taken that's how I have my memory
locations rather than days and so yeah
coming to San Francisco and having
people like Andrew and Zack and a lot or
even two was like showing us around and
taking us to good spots was kind of
invaluable have you guys been up to
like the muir woods not yet I was gonna
go with my aunt and uncle when they came
here but that didn't end up happening
why dude I know it will amaze Gregg and
Jenn have a car now
so I'm just gonna hop in with them what
did that happen
alright they got a car yeah whew oh it
was literally the first week of
quarantine it was the first week of
quarantine because they were the
dealerships last customers before they
closed so I'm excited get up get up get
up especially a great story about it the
way he tells it it's like the script for
an episode of 24 just like I remember
telling you things and typically that's
when I talk to my family so I'm gonna
move things around and you know talk to
my family on Sundays and we're gonna go
hiking and stuff it is we went up there
to Stinson Beach and we stayed up there
for for two weeks there is a place that
I am dying to stay around there called
the Pelican Inn yes do you know it yes I
am dying to go there cuz it's just
basically this perfect British variant
and we were in talks actually last year
to shoot something there and there
didn't happen in the end but it was a
Tolkien episode of a show that we do
called true fiction and I picked that
place because it looks like a place that
Tolkien would hang out in and the the
general manager it was emailing me he
said God thank you for saying that
because I actually wanted to rename our
pub the Prancing Pony ah I assumed some
lawyers might object to that but mainly
Saul Zaentz who owns the Tolkien estate
um I cannot recommend it it's the same
thing it's like look you go across the
bridge and hour later you're in a
different world in a different world and
it's the most enchanted we went up there
and we cut a record over two weeks and
we were on top of Mount Tamalpais and so
you looked out of her the Muir Woods or
the Pacific Ocean and it was just like
one of the best places to create so I
cannot I cannot recommend it enough and
it's then we're talking to some friends
up from Wales and they're like we're
thinking I think we're gonna go back to
the snow we're in the UK and he said but
before we do that they've got a two kids
a four-year-old and a one-year-old he's
like we want to just drive across the
country is like you absolutely should it
is everybody lives in the States if
you've never I would say to do it in
your 20s or 30s is the perfect time to
do it later
late 20s early early 30s to go from LA
to New York or New York to LA and you
can do it in a week if you take your
time and it's just
again it's the same thing if like
realizing like and
were separated only by distance and by
miles and once you remove that layer you
realize that we're so similar and it's
just the most connecting thing you could
possibly do and you get to see it
beautiful this is a beautiful country
but to understand its history to
understand its cultures and to
understand the people that live to me is
incredibly informative and necessary to
our own unique experience in our own
story without that just gonna keep doing
this rinse repeat we'll keep doing the
same thing over and over cuz I I can't
drive which you can't choose not but you
could I mean yeah I could I could I mean
every it's like a golf cart over here
it's all automatic it's fine rules of
the road yes but that I feel like that's
a big thing that's holding me back and
actually I'm not I'm not really one for
New Year's resolutions or anything but I
did you know the start of the year I did
think to myself I need I need to learn
how to drive I think I've moved to this
country I'm seeing a lot of one
particular state I mean III you know
I've come out to visit devs here before
most of it's either LA or or even
Montreal but you know I know those two
places so well and I I'm doing myself a
disservice because I don't know how to
drive I could just get a zip car and go
somewhere temp does it not just sound
like she pitched a show yeah this sounds
like a Opie show I can drive but I
haven't got my Nathan's hair so we could
you know they transfer everything
everything we've discussed so far seems
like it could be turned into one show
where try me and Lucy just travel the
country and try to use all of his stuff
guys I am down like I'm serious let's
get it we could do this on our phones
just hold on a second we got a show we
got a pitch you you get some game spot
budget behind this and
I will take one week and I will I will
show you it's it's literally this is
this is my stop like I've done this
before and so it's a fantastic badge of
honor
you go from LA to Winslow Arizona okay
there's fuck-all to see there but two
things then you go from Winslow to Santa
Fe New Mexico
which is a divergent thing is you got to
go through Albuquerque and you just take
a left at Albuquerque like Bugs Bunny
and you go up to Santa Fe and you get to
see this really cool the Santa Fe is
just like encased in history and culture
and it's just beautiful and then you go
to Oklahoma City and then you go from
Oklahoma to Nashville and you take a
left at Nashville and you go up to
Washington DC and you pass by 1600
Pennsylvania and flip the bird and you
keep going and it is it is just a it's
an amazing like I have the hotel's
mapped out I have the restaurants mapped
out it is just it's it's the coolest
trip and yet by the time you get done
you're like because the only thing
that's between you and those cities is
hours of driving and so it's
you share music with each other and you
go wait a minute
if you never listen to whatever I'm like
nom never listen that album before is
like we got nothing to do for the next
eight hours but learn about each other
or learn about yourself if you did it by
yourself you're like man I better be
good company and you just dive into
either podcasts we got into I think but
what I did it that's when cereal had
just popped and so it was just like holy
[ __ ] we have a thought we did but you
can in the podcast you listen to albums
you never listen to you or you or you
have conversations with people or you
just sit in silence and be comfortable
with that it's it's it's the coolest
thing man it's the cool isn't it
well well we're putting over a pinch and
see where we get with that I send this
to our bosses yeah we got some questions
for you please far away far away I put a
call out on Twitter calm so before you
get to that we get those questions yes
you chat has been talking and it's
mainly been talking about your role as
pain do you remember doing that cause I
am in Naruto yeah just a bunch of people
just saying they loved your your work in
that and screw that yeah good work and
they will be able like they're not
watching this chat they're not gonna
talk about pain
we are watching trust me we're watching
one of the most important characters to
me and that show there's a huge show
like like it covers the swath of this
but but to be able to have such a
character that goes who this guy is pure
evil obviously bad guy and you go nope
ladies yes layers upon layers yeah I
mean that that was a that was a big
honor for me I'm glad that it remains so
much to people yeah all right
oops you riot seeing such Roy has
already voiced many great videogame
characters is that are there any
characters or is there a franchise you
wish you'd given part of man I this is a
very very popular question and for good
reason um the last time I did this I
think it was actually you guys that put
out a was just a random tweet they're
like mmm my man so good one other Marvel
game would you love to see happen and I
tweeted out I said cough cough bill roof
Kafka and
next thing you know it becomes this
story and because bill responds back he
was like you are definitely a man
without fear and yeah and so people were
like oh [ __ ]
Marvel games just a dusty gonna do
daredevil game and I was like pull my
and bill actually had to put a statement
I was like hold on inside joke between
Troy and I because when we're on set for
Avengers I came to him and I said
somehow we started talking about this I
was like look if they ever if you guys
ever decide to do a Marvel game or a
daredevil game I just want to read for
it just want to read for it daredevil
was like my first graphic novel that I
ever read was Batman and then some
people got a despite of and some people
got into Green Lantern whatever mine
that I was like I'm gonna get into this
dude was daredevil and that was like my
first serialized comic-book experience
that I like got issue after issue after
issue and when I fell away from comics
as I grew up it actually was on that
trip to Japan um was when the comiXology
app hit on the iPad and so I when I was
like I'm gonna pick up I wonder if I
could find that my favorite daredevil
issue on comiXology
and then I found it was like holy [ __ ]
just instantly I remember having that
trade in my hand and reading through
this where I was in my life where I even
was when I was reading it and so I just
got back in a terrible because all son
was like well well what did I miss a
whole lot of stuff and so I went through
and I binge read all of daredevil so I
can't DeRozan I was like you know if you
guys ever decide to do this I just want
to read for it cuz this is my not only
his he's my he's my Marvel character um
but
we play games because the
player-character do things that we can't
they can run faster they can fly that
you dude they could drive whatever it is
how do you create a game where
the player-character
do something that they can't
that to me is just like a super
compelling problem to solve
I suppose like I want that game to be
made and I want to be a part of that um
and just yeah so that people ask me all
the time is like what's the franchiser
rule you what everyone do is like
daredevil daredevil daredevil daredevil
daredevil and I got a chance to sit down
with Charlie Cox talk to him and it's
like look man when I found out you were
gonna play this I'm a huge fan of
Boardwalk Empire and I was like I love
love you as an actor I love your work on
that I folded my arms and it's like hold
on a second you can have blonde hair or
red hair you can't be up this black
haired Irish dude it's like you can't do
that and then first couple of episodes
try to hide the exit and finally go
we've got great ratings [ __ ] it it's
just like let your whole accent out um
it was just so kind of like you changed
that role for me so I don't want to try
to ever compete with anything cuz that
Netflix show saying the same thing with
Vincent D'Onofrio man just reinvented
the role of Wilson Fisk it was just like
an incredible incredible I don't know I
can't say enough about that show but
yeah so there's longest answer to the
shortest question ever
daredevil daredevil Daryl daredevil
dot-com hashtag Bill Roseman hashtag Mar
will make a new game there you go let's
get the campaign going
Cuneo clipped out and we'll get that
rolling as well I very much Ellie from
from PR going shut up Jimmy Allen asks
Troy any game or games are you which
games are you looking forward to playing
in the coming months actually I don't
know absolutely completely are you
kidding me yes you take yourself though
um if I look if I focus on that that I
didn't do my job
um because my job because if I can do it
then you're gonna do it too right you're
gonna pick the part and go Charles
Gregory has the worst
British accent ever and then I failed
good job
I I think that my job as an actor is to
hopefully disappear behind that role and
all you see is that character III
the dream is to liken myself in a new
way to gary oldman because for years I
had no idea what Gary Oldman look I saw
him instead Nancy I saw him in lie all
of these different roles it's not real
who had to have dialect training because
he forgot his actual accent yeah because
he played different roles and that's
like like Daniel day-lewis oh yeah I
that that to me is just an extremity
that that that is someone who is a as I
understand it he's an incredibly kind
and compassionate person he runs a cause
a cobbler and he runs like a shoe
shopping is like home little town was it
no for my Leslie yeah my foot so III
don't not mean to disparage him I don't
know him so how dare I speak negatively
against him I just as far as the way
that he works that's not something that
I want to do that I don't believe in
just like for getting away of the guys
want Oscars though so I mean I guess
there's something to be said for that
for me as a gamer all I want to do is
make a game that I want to play so if I
and I tried that but if I get a birthday
present or whatever I literally will
close my eyes before I open think as I
love as many layers of separation in
suspense as I can't so even with the
last of us Neal was like do you want to
see some like no I don't see anything I
don't see anything I just want to see
how you have I want see the finished
product when it comes to something that
I personally am making I enjoy the
iterative process but it when it's
something that I'm a part of being made
dad I want to see it's like show me the
finished product show me exactly what it
was like because I know what my part of
it is and they'll be able to see the
finished product to me it's just so
rewarding so yeah I mean I've got stacks
of games either all my hard driver or
all around me here of games that I play
it I can't think of one it's off the top
of my head that I haven't in some way
experience but by and large I'd love to
pick up the controller I buy them
[Music]
even if somebody gives me one I'll keep
it for like more of a keepsake but I
still love to I'll buy it download it
and load it up and play it just because
I love I love experiencing it to me
there's some people that don't need this
and they don't agree with this but in
order for me to understand what it is
that I need to do I feel like I need to
understand
the the end result like that what's we
see end products be able to speak of the
in English you know so yeah absolutely I
play often one what's something that you
this is a question for me like yes thank
you I uh your position in games right
now like what would you go and tell
yourself when you're first starting out
doing performance capture and voice work
and how do you think anything you've
changed over that time like is it easier
for you to hold into roles no no I think
it's still just as challenging I think
that I have more tools
[Music]
and I'm equipped more to be able to
navigate into that
I think for the longest time I know I
don't think I know I
people have a myself included have the
problem of continuing to audition after
you got the role because there's this
this feeling of I don't deserve this and
I I thought for the longest time is like
someone's gonna find out that I'm not
good and boy on that day they'll be like
you fooled us for a long time but we're
on to you now and that just doesn't
serve me nor does to serve the project
especially the character but I remember
speaking of my associate of San Diego
pause Paul Crocker fellow Brit sat me
down he's like I wanna take you to
drinks this is a San Diego comic-con he
was like I want to get a drink so I got
something to tell you and I had just
auditioned for
but for the Joker or Arkham origins and
he goes they're gonna give it to you and
I went oh no I don't think that's the
right move for me right now man he's
like well you should say yes I'm like
now and so I turned it down and then
[Music]
they came back and they offered I turned
it down and turned it down twice
it cut to a Eames curtain who's the head
of Warner Brothers games at the time
copy into his office and was like I want
to show you something and he played back
my audition because they had filmed it
for reference and he goes that's really
good I was like thank you you guys no
you don't understand we think that's
really good and we're really smart you
need to get over yourself and trust us
that we're not gonna make you look bad
and we think you should do this so it
was full total impostor syndrome because
I was afraid of failing and so if I
could go back and tell myself anything
it's like
sure it's not just
Jew in there by herself you're
surrounded by a team of incredibly
talented people that want you to succeed
and I think that I spent more time
trying to impress rather than just
simply Express and I've found great
comfort in going in to a situation going
I'm gonna do my best at this and if
you're willing to you know let me make
some mistakes and help me along the way
I think we can actually both really
interesting and by and large those have
been the roles and the opportunities
that have not only served me best but
that people have come back and said hey
that really that one really meant
something it's the one where I came in
it was like watch this [ __ ] and think I
was gonna impress everybody that they're
like yeah you're okay or you sucked um
but my job as an actor is come in and
just understand something that nobody
else understands about that character
and show them what the character looks
like not how good Troy because if I'm
just trying to show you how good I can
act
you're gonna go Charles Gregory had a
shitty brother George Gregory is
underrated I think I go to follow up on
that like impostor syndrome is something
that a lot of people struggle with like
especially in the creative field and
also you know pretty much any job right
so how how did it feel especially for a
character like Joker you had people on
that were working you know with the
character telling you you could do it
but I imagine there was still that
element of like are people going to love
me because you were following on for
Arkham origins specifically you were
following mark hamill oh yeah
so my mind goes back to I think it was
New York comic-con 2013 where you on
stage and you did The Killing Joke
monologue in your voice and that was the
moment when I was like yes this is this
this is perfect like can you remember
what it was like yeah some of the impact
it might it might have had on your
imposter syndrome to have a roaring
crowd just burst out with approval what
was that like
it was visceral hmm but that moment was
not to me the unlock moment
right
because I had
they as marketing the team everybody was
like hey we Eric who is that are the
creative director on that was like
people want to see this man they want to
hear Rogers Batman they want to hear
your Joker that's why you're here I was
like yeah man it's just I really want to
make sure that people experience that
character and just give him this
[ __ ] and he sat me down in the
corner and he was like
tell me the truth why do you don't want
to do it I'm scared man I'm scared that
if I get out there and I do a bad job
this could hurt the game
to me goes is Ascot and he goes is that
whole place they made a great game I
don't think you can [ __ ] it up
and I win
yeah
even if I was just atrocious to think
that I had the ability single-handedly
to tank a game
the arrogance behind nough and the
complete disregard for the hundreds of
people besides myself that had worked
tirelessly for years to make that game
good
but I
ability to make or break that game
and I went mad because you need to go
out there you need to give people the
opportunity to support you
to show you that you're good so I went
out there man and I don't get this I
just that's not me I I've born on a
state
um I the bigger the crowd the better I
am but I went out there and I was
nervous
and
I remember
going into the mic
and saying that furs like memories can
be vile and there was no sound at all
there was nothing and I looked up and I
was like
well you know what you gave it your best
and so I just powered through
and I just finished it and I was like I
was right I am not good people are not
going to accept this and Roger was the
first one to go
whoo and the proudest with gosh there's
like in in the video I remember it
because I've seen I've seen it so many
times cuz it's just like it I've heard
Hamel my entire life like me too like
you I'm a huge huge fan of the animated
series and the Arkham games and I've
seen that I just like to see people do
Joker voices because they become that
character as a human like if you watch
the behind the scenes of the development
Diaries of Arkham City and then an
Arkham night and even Arkham Asylum like
hammers face contorts in a way that I
don't see it and like so the reason I
watch it is like to see if what what
that is that you can see the impact
Joker has on a voice actor and you can
see that in your on again and it's most
evident the moment your define it ends
on a loss and then the moment the laugh
ends you can see you go from Joker to
Troy and you're like you reel back in
the chair and like put your hand over
your face and you can see like a genuine
reaction to the actual crowd happening
and I think maybe I'm being presumptuous
but I think that might have been the
moment when the fear left you because
you could you can see like you're
looking around and you can see like
you're even like welling up a bit in
that yes so it was an absolutely
incredible moment if no one's if you
haven't seen it like just search for
Troy Baker visage Killing Joke
monoclinic joke monologue and you will
see it and it's just like a a pure
moment in time wise man it is because
there were multiple people that were
present in in that moment within me it's
it's it's the actor that I was on that
day in New York it was the actor that
audition it was the actor that said no
it was the actor in Ames office was this
convergence and it's the kid who was 6
years old that bought his first Batman
graphic novel but the first it was the
kid who ran home from school after being
picked on and laughed at
at 3:30 to be in front of the TV so he
could watch Batman animated series
whatever Appa sewed was being offered to
me that they excited no choice yeah and
so you we would watch the same episodes
that went over Kim's repeat so we
couldn't just select their menu and
shoes and it was all of that it was it
was the the kid who realized holy wait
mark hamill the same same guy that did
Luke Skywalker's also the Joker and the
person who had would seen Mark Hamill
come back
after
fifteen years
not doing it
to to being in Arkham Asylum and that
being my second
you know favorite graphic novel
standalone graphic I was sitting right
there on my shelf um then when I found
out they're gonna do Arkham Asylum was
like that's gonna be the most how do you
taint change that and make that into a
game um am I gonna be able to cut my
hand we know with glass just to keep
myself and going and saying it's like oh
that's all those beautiful moments
but I remember mark and I have met on a
handful of occasions not more than a
handful
and we were at a ki Li show the the Game
Awards and I was I was leaving in mark
was was backstage
and
hey Mark Troy Baker catch me it's like
gonna meet you
all right good to see you I could see
you too but I kept going I feel uh stuff
my shoulder and I was like turn around
he goes I thought I had I had to ask my
daughter did I do a game and forget
about it he goes you were magnificent
music you did such a great job and
something that mark I don't say yes to
the Joker unless market said no period
to this day and and that there has been
times when someone has approached me and
and and they said we want you to do this
I'm like have you asked mark the like I
mean no it's like then you gotta ask him
if he says no then I'm your man but if
if he says yes it needs to go to him and
Mark and I'm for a time at the same
agent and Mark caught wind of that and
he was like you're a stand-up kid I was
like I just it when I say that you're my
Joker you're my Joker man and I am a
custodian of it for a time but my job is
an actor it to I not only show you what
the character looks like but hopefully
in doing so I move the needle a little
bit and show you something about
character that you may have never known
or because you take the character like
the Joker and it's just like that's one
of the greatest characters of literature
never going to be able to be better than
mark hamill but if I could be different
and show you something that you never
knew about him
they don't have done something just a
quick reminder I mean we're so engrossed
in the conversation we keep forgetting
to plug the things that were supposed to
be plug in yeah please donate covered
relief efforts we're raising money for
health care workers fighting kovat you
can see the links on the screen bit or
lyo for /gs - covet
we're also donating money donating money
raising money and donating it to black
lives matter which is bit or ly 4 / GS -
BLM we've had a 25 dollar donation from
jeremy Oris towards black lives matter
thank you so much please donate if you
can if you can't share share the link
and that people know that trey is here
drop in knowledge and heartfelt
recounting of his career up until this
point but yeah Lucy do we have any more
questions uh yeah we do um Jakob McCourt
fan of guess what after dark and on
discord I just started playing death
drowning and you're in it can you tell
us what it was like to work with you
tell us what it was like to work with
Kojima while playing Higgs and actually
your work on mgs 5 - two men I I will
tell you I will tell you I know this as
a I'm a huge metal gear fan when I heard
when I heard there was a different
person doing an ocelot voice I was like
and then when I heard the voice that was
like sonic again he's done it again
thank you the beauty of that was that I
quickly that that news of me playing
Ocelot I I quickly was upstaged by oh
there's also gonna be a different snakes
oh and just for the for what it's worth
um David Hayter is is fantastic but as
someone who has played a role that's
been played by other other actors again
I can't hold on too tightly to a
character because that makes the
character too small
I like big characters and characters
that could be played by you can't say
like though this is the one person they
do you remember Martin Freeman played
Richard 3 in the West End for a short
time and everybody at first was like
look you're really good we like to in
Sherlock we
like you in this but you don't need to
do Richard the third because there's a
special kind of person that's supposed
to do Richard the third and what ended
up doing was showing you a completely
different version of that character and
people there's been people have said
that's their favorite rendition of it um
and to have someone who Richard three
supposed to be this big bombastic
character into play by this you know
the basic British Woody Allen in
performance not another anyway but the
self-deprecating that kind of thing it
was it was a an amazing opportunity and
I can't imagine
Martin Freeman just really throwing
himself into that go watch this that's
curve ball they drew but
Keifer came in
and rolled with every punch for whatever
reason he didn't understand that they
were gonna be doing facial capture so he
showed up and they're like because like
why is there a camera here and we think
need you to be we need your lines
memorized and all this and he was like I
need a moment and he walked outside and
he smoked about a half pack cigarettes
and he came back in he goes let's go to
work and he threw himself into it he
also understood I talked about the video
game awards he gave his speech he was
like I because of how your reaction and
how you guys feel about this character
has made me love this character and I
just I can't say enough about his work
ethic it made sense what the story why
they did it you haven't played it much
less if you let that be the reason why
you didn't experience phantom pain dude
it is if you're a metal gear fan it's
it's the pretty little bow that that
Kojima was able to go all of these
things that you didn't think would
matter whatever wouldn't come back to
all of it just converges on itself and
it's like you remembered something from
peace walker that like no one else
whatever thought is like all of it comes
back into play it's so great tons of
flippity there was like the way that he
tied stuff up was crazy but I walked
into that session and I didn't realize
that today was gonna be that I'm like
holy crap but he's like there's classes
and everything like okay
[Music]
and they're looking at the script and I
looked down and I I see I see the line
and I was like I get
I get to say this things like yeah so I
couldn't help I was like you're pretty
good I just I I had to like so that was
it was super fun and you know you I've
said this before a bit like you actors
will say you know love to work with you
again and it's almost like just a
industry polite way of
that's a greeting you know it's like the
look I would love to work with you again
but I was like III didn't expect him to
hold me to that
or when he said is like would love to
work with you kids like cats a planet
you know it sure but we have with a
great time but I don't think I didn't
expect that and then he's tapping me on
the shoulder at uh again San Diego
comic-con because I want to introduce
you to your co-star to turn over and
it's Norman Reedus I'm like what is
happening right now
I like checking my Drake going who'd who
gave this to me
so first day on set man and there's so
many moments that happened in between
with Henao and I that that were that
were cool and just reaffirming of him as
both the genius and just that one of the
coolest people but I'm on set and
there's Norman and literally one of the
first things we have to do we're kind of
walking it through and it was like it so
you lick Norman's face I'm like yeah
uh-huh so how do you want how do you
want to do that you need to lick his
face I'm like yeah but I mean do I do I
do I need to and again Norman was so
what's so funny about it and it was like
let's get weird man let's just let's
just do this it was like cool so I got
to lick Norman space for the first scene
that guy has the most incredible work
ethic I thought were you gonna say that
guy has that some reason it tastes like
raspberries I don't know why his haze
tastes like red reduce raspberries I
don't know that guy was down for
anything and
rapping one day sounds like so you take
some time off it's like nah man I'm
going to Germany and shooting the show
ride that I'm doing I'm like when do you
rest he's like never making up for lost
I'm like get it so I mean that guy is
same thing he's like first in last out
on Walking Dead works harder than
anybody else you'll ever see
I was down for anything didn't go to his
trailer when we were shooting he was
right on set with everybody else ate
lunch with everybody else was down for
anything all only one of the scenes to
be good yeah I he's he's a good dude
good - we got a $25 donation towards
blacklivesmatter from Corey Tay
thank you very much appreciated yeah I
guess one of the things I wanted to ask
you was about how much obviously people
know I'm not really sure how to phrase
this question I people know us certain
voices Joe and Hooker and Jason Todd and
whoever it may be many many others but
like sometimes I like I was looking at
you IMDB page and you're in formal
alchemists and you're a former Alchemist
Brotherhood as greed how much do you
remember those kind of characters that
perhaps on always brought up every day
like you know Dampier in Soul Calibur
broken destiny or you know some random
other character do you do you still like
draw on those characters as well because
I imagine everyone's always like can we
get a little bit of Joel can we get a
little bit Jason Todd can we give it
like has anyone ever gone Caliban
we have pain from Naruto if anyone is
ever like we want a little bit of Joel
I'm like we need to expand that
character because of that character they
exist somewhere else
and if you're wanting it to be
if you want to include elements of that
person then that's that's a pretty
shoddy character like you need to give
you a new person play right but and
whatever my level of involvement with
the character was to say it's like I
really feel like I became man in hat be
for that one episode of some show that
never aired
however much a Giunta
and a character yeah there's there's
always that something something remain
and there's people that have experienced
friend of mine is musician and and he's
the guy that's played arena tours and
he's won Grammys and all of this stuff
and he was just talking about how in a
middle of a song he'll I forgot the
words I'm like how can you forget the
word like Paul McCartney playing um uh
what was it Coachella I think it was oh
forgot the words - Hey Jude
does only reading like full and he just
had this moment it took I 75 first of
all and he goes forgot the words and the
whole comes like well yeah I'd love a
pushin but I was like what an amazing
how could you possibly forget that
there's this my son is fascinated with
the Beatles right now and he has a
favorite album sergeant pepper's but he
could he'll like Eleanor Rigby will come
on he'll just stop and look up and go
revolver he's well he's a he'll sink he
loves to see yellow submarine paint dude
and I want to hold your hand those are
the three so he's like covering like
like the the help Beatles he's also
covering the White Album feels he's
doing good
but there's this everybody should watch
this because my wife and I have broken
this video down like like forensically
um
it is the 1969 live broadcast version of
so this is like Abbey Road version or
like era Beatles and they're playing on
some show and they perform Hey Jude live
and it is
I every time I watch it I get I just get
goosebumps because it's he was like the
the host whoever the host is he was like
for the first time performing in front
of a live audience in quite some time
this is the Beatles and this is like the
band's about to break up you know they
come together for for a beer oh just one
last time to be a band and after this
they're all gonna leave um and to see
like there's John and George next to
each other and like they're not even
alive anymore
and you get to see a young Paul
McCartney and a young star at a young
John no George
and there there's this one moment where
John looks over at Paul our Pollux and
shot is like are you gonna sing kind of
like you know sing with me and John
looks at him like it's the next so
that's not right now
I was like how could you forget to play
Hey Jude and it's because they probably
hadn't played it together since they
recorded it because they didn't tor hmm
so there's characters that I've done run
like yo man that was my Tuesday
afternoon session and you've played that
game 20 time because it's your favorite
game it doesn't diminish the lie the
performance of the game
if I'm like I forgot that line I didn't
I I had completely forgotten about that
to me it's something that is a beautiful
experience that it's the same thing
we're talking about where that hole in
the wall taco place now has import and
more value to me because of your story
because of your experience that line
that I just kind of said you're like
dude there's so much wait line like I'd
forgotten about that like your story now
makes that line have more value to me
because there's a shared experience
beyond just my session
hmm did you plan that did you plan for
to bring it back around the conversation
quite as beautifully as you just did
there no III feel look we're all telling
one story we're just telling different
chapters of it you know my story is your
story is your story it's just different
versions and different perspectives of
it but I quite enjoy our conversation
each other
I know passing on show flaws so I'm very
glad we got a chance i I was just
thinking I loved that moment at MCM
London where we were texting each others
like where are you and it felt like it
oh yeah trying to find you were like
doing an autograph signing out at the
time yeah yeah yeah but it was like I
was I felt like it was a roomful of
strangers and I got to see a friend and
we just like this weird going over like
okay well goodbye almost over like eight
great dance it was like I me do you want
to do a little dance you did you want to
it there's so much fun but I just felt
that was a great moment and that's when
I find that you're moving to LA you I
think you were one of the first people I
ever told that they'd asked me because I
think they just asked and you asked me
what was going on in my life um but no
it's actually strange thinking back
you're one of the people I've known in
the industry maybe the longest yeah I
think I met you 2013 yeah yeah 22 so
maybe even 20 2012 we were starting to
do early press for Last of Us yeah but
maybe well I can get by shock to my
interview do you a lot something you're
just lucky young naive what hair color
see James oh man you've had it is I
think you got me beat because I've had
my hair has been every color of the
rainbow
well this is this is my natural color
for the first time since about 2010 so
this is good for you you're all grown up
no no you read some Erika
bring back the red that's why I said was
solid shocking red I remembered I just
remember the first time I interviewed
you try I bet you don't remember it was
in London it was four infamous seconds
daddy in the bus that bust was the
smallest thing I have like I was I was
like this it was like I could see that
pitch happening I was like oh that's
gonna be it get this and then we like
have this cool like renovated bus that
that's where everyone will do all the
interviews and it was just the weirdest
most awkward for everybody everybody
considered shoot through the windows for
like okay that's not gonna there was
another one that we did in in Rome that
was super cool where it was freezing and
they had these like heaters that were in
there never were just kind of like
crowded around all the heaters I loved I
loved because they don't really do press
events like those anymore for games and
there are some if you think back to the
story there are some old really bizarre
ones I was that Splinter Cell event
where they basically put people in a
hangar but the debug consoles ran so hot
that a journalist almost passed out you
were neither of you were at the
Uncharted for one no I was not the one
in London but no no but I know the one
you I'd know the one you mean that
deliver yeah Holly Bennet was there
where you guys were chilling out in the
air did they send from the states maybe
I don't know no it was all it was all
your crazy yeah up in Scotland that was
like why are we in Rome and nothing
Scotland and great cold
[Music]
rome wasn't mold almost beautiful was
perfect line
gonna say well what are your bringing it
back to our questions how where's your
ambition in video games now do you want
to stop making it because you've been
talking little bits here and there and
like mainly you've been right now that
you've been doing like musical streams
on Instagram and that kind of stuff it
seems like you're doing a lot of
experimentation and you've mentioned
like game ideas before and is that
something I want to put you more yeah
Austin Wintory and I have been he's a
dear friend and just an absolute dream
of a partner he he and I both have like
okay if we could make a game what kind
of game will we make and what's great is
at that dice we had an opportunity to
sit down and we were talking his shoe
and
we start talking about before I've had
this story and I'm wondering which
version in store are you gonna tell them
that so Oh though it's only the truth we
we sit down awesome I sit down and we're
just kinda talking it's like hey man
we're kind of setting out we're starting
to to make games just your hand and your
words have guided more especially
independent studio so we would if if
you're able to sit and and have a drink
with those we kind of like offer any
wisdom you know it's the same thing that
anybody asked me is like what if I
wanted to get in this what do I want to
do and so she looks at me he goes
you have an idea was like yeah we think
we have a great idea he goes are you
gonna pitch me or not we're like here we
go it's that we start pitching Chu in
about 15 minutes later we end and Austin
goes so uh so yeah that's our idea
and whereas Shu has not said a word um
so Austin goes yeah that's that's our
idea and we're really excited it she
looks up he goes see that that's what I
don't get
well like what he goes you're excited
about this idea that's what I don't
understand I was like oh no no and gave
us the Mo's I it was it was such a good
I understand why Shuhei Yoshida is
Shuhei you she because what he is like
look man I know that you may talk to
this to your friends so they're like aw
that's a great idea he was like but I'm
the guy that when you pitch I break out
the checkbook and I go okay here's money
to go make that dream possible so I
really appreciated his honest and he was
like here's here's what you guys are
missing here's what you're lacking
and so later it's at the dice Awards so
I'm I'm presenting and Bethel is in
front of me and he's just kind of
standing there tall man child and love
Mike so much he's just kind of like
rocking on his heels and it's like okay
we both know what happened and so I'm
like so we talk to shooters oh oh and
how did that go and I was like well and
I told him and he just kind of put his
hand on my shoulder and him it's like
welcome to the club because we have all
had that conversation with shoe and it
was just like that level of fraternity
is what I really really want because
I've had the opportunity to work with
developers and sometimes be an answer do
or a solution to a problem that they
have it's like we have this character
right now it's a problem because we
don't know how to bring it to life and
if I am ever the opportunity in the
position to be able to solve that
problem for them that's been a that's
been a win in my book and because of
that and just like you guys I've been
able to make friendships I love this
industry I'm not doing this because I
don't know it's just my nine-to-five gig
it's like I am loved this industry I
love making game and now where I'm at i
I I want to see if I can't leverage this
to a position where Austin and I are
whomever I had the opportunity to do
this with sure we make a kind of game
that
just me being hired to do a role but
it's actually me being able to hire
people to do this I want to build a team
and I'm not I'm not a Lucas Pope I can't
do a game all by myself
um I'm more like a Mike Bethel where
it's like I wanted to bring in the
people that I trust people that I know
and together let's let's tell a story
that we're all proud say Tristan there's
a like a lot of not a lot of but like a
few different instances of people who
would not to pigeonhole your talents
because there are many talents but like
people who would traditionally be
thought of as voice actors moving into
that territory like the one that sticks
out for me is another friend of GameSpot
Abu Bakr Salim who is a who voiced by
akin Assassin's Creed origins just set
up a studio in the UK to start making
games with good man and it's from BAFTA
so maybe you guys should work on
creating this community of like nude
voice actors and I'm sure Abby would be
well off for chatting to you about the
ins and outs of that and seeing where
you guys are at hi I had no idea that he
had ambitions to do that like he was on
the BAFTA Committee yeah formants is a
solid dude really nice guy yeah he's so
good but yeah he's doing it as well and
they've set up a little studio and
they're working on stuff so dude you
just reminded me too I have to do a
video for
for BAFTA I love that organizations so
much because they especially not only do
they have this done such a great job of
recognizing the talent and the skill and
the accomplishment people within this
industry but they also are really keen
to identify the future talent and help
foster and sponsor that talent and so
they reached out to me and said hey can
you do something for the people that the
young game developers who have won those
awards so I've got to do that so I'm
gonna jump onto that but I'm um I love
it doesn't have to be III doesn't have
to be diaster doesn't Comicon supposed
to be able to to be able to do this the
beauty of this situation is that it is
forced us not forced us challenged us to
find creative ways to connect and I love
that normally this would be relegated to
a press event or some kind of like
formalized you know four-walled event
that said now we can sit down and I'll
have 5 10 15 minutes with you guys but I
love that we can just jump on and do
this not only be able to have a great
conversation but also I love watching
these numbers go up so thank you to
everybody during this time that I've
been able to be a part of this
conversation too we've donated a black
lives matter into the code relief
you think you jumped up like over a
thousand dollars I think I've been doing
this so that's that's incredible
yeah and we're gonna be running for the
next five or so weeks toi thank you so
much for joining us today
pleasure speaking to you tomorrow
we're actually geeking of Roger Craig
Smith we've got Roger on tomorrow with
Justin Exley we're gonna be playing some
ethics legends with Watson and Mirage
please message I'll pass it on yes
please ask him to do that's what a man
does please
have you not have you not seen this no
go to his Instagram
and I don't know what what Vito first of
all he's in him I Roger nothing
I love he is one of the most
interesting dudes and is is genuinely
and probably the funniest person that I
know he on his Instagram he did a video
and I wanted to do more of these because
I I've watched it multiple times and
every time I laugh he is one of the
funniest uh film day he started out
doing stand-up and he won't do stand-up
anymore um he's doing okay but he's just
he's a brilliant photographer he's one
of the most humble truly gracious and
grateful people that I know and he's
just you have to you have to watch that
video go to what that's what I mean I've
made a note he was I was messaging him
earlier because we're doing some tech
tests and I said I'm terrible at apex he
said don't worry me too
and I said you know let's let's make it
for the stream you know you will get out
of bronze and he just went alright now
that's my name too high yeah I I am
envious you guys are gonna have such a
great time so yeah whenever you need me
I am here I'm at your behest talk about
my bad British accents and we'll pitch
that story or that that show to GameSpot
and get them to put us on the road we'll
just rotate this hell yeah
all right Troy thank you so much for
joining us thank you everyone in the
chat who's been joining along the
conversation to like I said we'll be
back again tomorrow with Roger Craig
Smith and Justine Huxley play some apex
legends see them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]